Chris Mannix is in Rio right now back
live on the Dan Patrick show Chris
Mannix jay mohr you there buddy yeah jam
here talk about that oh that's what
happens who takes to blame if this team
loses last night to Australia well I
mean I blame as hard as its upward to
use because even though this team is far
more talented than everybody else
continuity matters in these situations
it mattered for Argentina when they were
rolling in the early 2000s it mattered
for Spain in 2012 and it matters for
this Australian team a bunch of guys
have been playing together for a very
long time only two players j on this
Olympic team we're part of a 2012 team
that's ten new guys on the roster so
even though they're much better than
everybody else it does take time for
this group to come together but the
answer question before about why
Australia is so good they have really
prioritized basketball over the last ten
years the australian institute of sport
has developed these guys really well
that's why you see guys like dante x is
coming out into a different degree Ben
Simmons Sean maker this team in 2020 Jay
they are going to be the biggest threat
to USA basketball because of the stars
they were able to develop wow that's
quite a statement when Chris Mannix says
something like that you write it down
and pen next had to speak about things
he doesn't know about Australia is the
powerhouse coming around it's like when
the Cubans were dominating in boxing and
we thought we were the best in the world
Chris Mannix you were also covering bond
boxing in the Rio Olympics is it just
seems like the shine is completely left
boxing in its entirety as a sport in the
United States overtaken by mixed martial
arts in the Olympic Village I got to
think that other countries are way more
excited about boxing than the United
States tell me why I should be watching
boxing what am I looking for who should
I be looking towards well for starters
that the entire scoring system and much
of the system in general has changed
this year there's no headgear on the
men's athletes which makes a little more
exciting get to see a little more
power shots and the root scoring has
changed people to know Olympic boxing in
the past it's been scored kind of on a
pitty Pat punching system where if you
just touch a guy you kind of get a point
now they've evolved and gone to a more
professional style scoring system where
power shots count ring generalship
counts and that's actually worked out
really well for the USD I mean people
aren't talking about it right now Jay
because it's swimming and it's
gymnastics but the USA boxing men's team
is 6 in 1 / Rio they're guaranteed at
least one metal at this point because
Miko Hernandez a light flyweight one
last night this team has as stunned
everybody with how well they performed I
think a big part of that is because
they're scoring it more like
professionals and that's how these kids
are best excited Chris Mannix he waits
for the vertical hit him up on Twitter
let them know you love them from the Dan
Patrick show Chris be well my friend and
keep doing what you do you are the guy
you are the restaurant with a great
location and your foods good at to my
friend thanks come by the Dan Patrick
show pretty good you got it the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience